salut à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
titre en images de cette édition cet
homme vient d'entrer dans la légende du
cyclisme sur piste le nouvel ennemi
montrent un françois pervis a décroché
trois titres de champion du monde en
colombie il ya quinze jours il signe là
un triplé historique et inédit
interview vérité à suivre nous
reviendrons sur les dunes de la 17e
édition du 4l trophy avec un jeune
équipage mixte et saint quentinois parti
au maroc essentiellement pour l'
aventure humaine elle avait laissé leur
terrain d'entraînement pour transmettre
leur passion du basket à deux jeunes
filles des quartiers populaires
yvelinois des joueuses professionnelles
de calais était cette semaine les
marraines de coeur 2014 et évidemment
comme d'habitude en fin d'émission tous
les résultats du week-end mais tout
d'abord place à l'eco trail de paris
dans la deuxième partie d'émission comme
je vous le disais en titre nous parlons
du 4l trophy avec l'équipage mixte et
saint quentinois avec florine bréhat et
marc rozé bonsoir à tous les deux on va
tout d'abord évidemment parler de
l'eco-trail de cette course est
coresponsable semaine ce samedi 29 mars
va avoir lieu la 7ème édition de l'eco
trail de paris une course qui va se
dérouler notamment entre la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines et
paris tout près en fin de compte tenu de
la tour eiffel et du trocadéro qui peut
aller jusqu'à 80 kilomètres dans un des
formats et pour en parler l'organisateur
de l'eco-trail est présent jean charles
perrin bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là
tout d'abord vous pouvez nous nous
explique un petit peu le concept de
l'eco-trail
le concept est très simple c'est une
course nature dans un environnement qui
a priori s'y prête pas à savoir la ville
et on propose différents formats pour
qu'ils aient pas de barrière à la
participation à l'événement oui
justement dans les formats ya du 18 km
du 30km du 50 et du 80 km le 80 km c'est
du frais qui fait une distance en tout
cas qui fait peur dans on est à la
limite de ce qu'on appelle l'ultra trail
da - le trade format xl
ça fait pas peur à tout le monde pour
preuve ils vont être à peu près mille
huit cents ça fait pas si peur que ça
mais c'est vrai que ça se prépare
et comment on s'y prépare justement un
trait de cette distance avec beaucoup d
envie déjà et puis des sorties
régulières dans son nez sur trois quatre
cinq sorties semaine puis après pour
ceux qui veulent vraiment performer
parce qu'il y en a la majorité des gens
viennent ne pourrais te finisher donc
terminée pouvoir dire je les fais mais
rien qui viennent faire des temps donc
se montrer donc cela ils ont des des
programmes un peu plus chargé alors la
particularité de l'eco-trail c'est cet
aspect écologique vous essayé d'associer
l'effort physique justement la fibre un
petit peu écolos c'est ça dans cette
course-là
c'est dans notre adn en fait c'est pas
qu'une association c'est vraiment été
conçu comme ça c'était prouver que des
événements de masse puisque on va avoir
plus de dix mille personnes cette année
peuvent avoir une approche responsable
le trail c'est un constat semble ses
courses au contact de la nature
une nature plus de tribe donc on incite
à ce que les gens fassent attention à ça
c'est des transports ont incité
transports en commun on ramasse les
déchets en amont en aval on calcule la
pollution effective de nos coureurs
cette année on va attendre un événement
bio compostables c'est à tous les
déchets organiques on va les avoir triés
pour transformer en compost bon c'est
tout une démarche qui est pensé dès
l'origine pour prouver qu'on pouvait
organiser des événements tout en étant
respectueux a fait de notre
environnement je crois aussi que les
coureurs peuvent signer une charte
d'éthique quand ils s'inscrivent non
seulement ils peuvent mais doivent c'est
une obligation et c'est une charte qu'on
a décliné qui incite à se respecter
respecter les autres et respecter
l'environnement mais c'est vrai pour les
participants c'est vrai pour les
partenaires c'est vrai pour les
journalistes c'est vrai tout ce que les
accompagnateurs les bénévoles chacun
signe sacha pour participer à un
événement qu'on souhaite fédérateur
alors il n'y a pas que le trailer dans
l'eco trail de paris il ya aussi des
randonnées de la marche nordique le but
c'est quoi c'est d'essayer de favoriser
un peu et de mettre tout le monde à la
pratique du sport en général
c'est une illustration concrète de
manger bouger parce que si vous regardez
un peu la télé il ya beaucoup d'
incitation à faire ça et nous on a voulu
c'est vrai qu'au départ on a on a pensé
trails parce qu'on est on est pratiquant
et qu'on voulait un train de chenilles
en avait pas d'un come on a fait 1 mais
on y participe à mais c'est surtout un
principe de dire tout le monde peut en
être et nous notre ambition c'est qu'il
ait pas de frein à l'inscription de
l'eco-trail donc tout le monde court pas
ne serait-ce que dans l'entreprise avait
que 15 à 20% dès gens qui courent c'est
acquis et 80% des gens qui vont pas
courir on pas être concerné donc on a
dit bon on va faire des randonnées ça
s'est fait un peu par hasard parce que
le 18 et une incitation à la pratique
sportive elle est pas chronométrés dont
c'était allure libre et à 20% dès gens
qui avaient fait une randonnée donc on a
proposé des randonnées peu après les
résonances dans les écoutes et les gars
c'est bien les randos monde aimerait
bien avoir un truc un peu plus dynamique
la marche nordique commence à émerger
donc on a proposé de la marche et un est
donc maintenant en fait on a les randos
un peu classique les marches tandis
qu'un peu dynamique en a même une
compétition de marche nordique
maintenant le 18 le 30 le 50 80 donc en
principe en fait aujourd'hui nous manque
une seule marche c'est proposer quelque
chose d'à des gens qui aujourd'hui ne
bouge pas ne font rien donc ça c'est
projet 2015 s'est trouvé des programmes
qui incite les on va se préparer à un
jour participer à une de nos épreuves en
tout cas cette épreuve remonte bien que
l'on peut faire énormément de parcours
différents pour tous les niveaux en
ile-de-france et puis dans les yvelines
avec la base de loisirs les yvelines où
ils sont une terre un peu un peu
privilégiés avec les hauts-de-seine ces
deux départements dans lequel on fait
beaucoup de départs on emprunte beaucoup
de sentiers on a un territoire qui s'y
prêtent donc c'est aussi le pourquoi de
notre implication dans ce territoire
dernière question on en parlait en
préparant les missions cet eco trail
aussi permet d'engranger parce que c'est
une épreuve difficile d'engranger des
points en vue d'une éventuelle
participation au fameux l'ultra trail du
mont blanc c'est ça alors le 80
effectivement a demandé à ce que son son
épreuve soit éligible aux courses
qualificatives de zone ancien s'il fera
trail du mont blanc parce que c'est le
long de la course
ça donne deux points quand on est finie
champ de l'eco trail sachant que pour
faire l'ultra trail du mont blanc le
tour complet c7 il en faut c'est donc
nous on n'est qu'un petit bout de
hollywood on est une épreuve initiatique
en fait on a des parcours qui sont assez
roulant donc c'est mais je pense qu'il
faut aussi préparer aux montagnes ce
genre de preuve parce que les 10000
mètres de dénivelé vous les fêtes de
pâques avec l'eco trail et puis alors
pour les les coureurs qui vont partir
sur le 80 km ils vont partir à peu près
à midi 70 équipes il ça veut dire qu'ils
vont arriver vers quelle heure à peu
près au trocadéro j'imagine qu'à ses
ennuis nancy je prenais le départ
j'arriverai de nuit non les premiers
mais de 5h45 donc il fera pas nuit non
les premiers font moins de six heures et
le sol sera sec cette année donc je
pense que ça va aller dans ces eaux là
les plus les plus on va dire les plus
lents
ils ont jusqu'à une heure du matin ces
raisons le 13h et donc ça sera vrai
c'est quand la tour eiffel c'est un
d'accord très bien donc on peut se
donner rendez vous ce samedi pour le 80
km à la base de loisirs à midi pile
excès pour voir les traileurs partir de
saint quentin en yvelines merci beaucoup
jean charles perrin des tricks pas
saisir de 7,8 sport et à très bientôt
merci beaucoup lancé par la ligue
féminine de basket en 2005 l'opération
marraine de coeur permet de faire
découvrir le sport aux jeunes filles des
quartiers populaires cette année les
joueuses professionnelles de calais
faisait office entraîneur patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images
le contrôle du ballon est encore parfois
hésitant et pour cause la plupart de ces
jeunes filles jouent pour la première
fois au basket c'était bien la
précommande pas les shows pasquet et
confirmant la prochaine fois ci ont
repris du basket à l'école autre sera
pas faire sur des ateliers de passes de
tirs ou de dribbles ses jeunes
yvelinoise manie le ballon sur les
conseils des joueuses professionnelles
de calais actuellement en tête du
championnat de deuxième ligue féminine
elles sont venues partager leur passion
entre deux jours d'entraînement c'est
sûr que ça change de d'habitude après
c'est vrai que c'est toujours sympa
d'apprendre qu'ils aient nous notre
métier à des jeunes mais pourquoi pas
des futurs basket hand on essaie surtout
qu'elle s'amuse c'est une journée où
elle s'amuse et si elle s'amuse c'est
tellement aimé donc pour nous c'est tout
gagné initié il ya neuf ans par la ligue
féminine de basket
l'opération marraine de coeur est un
projet unique en france qui n'existe
dans aucune autre discipline l'objectif
dans les yvelines faire découvrir le
basket à des jeunes filles issus de
quartiers sensibles qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de côtoyer les parquets et
les terrains de sport c'est un leur
faire découvrir le sport 2 les mettre en
relation par atelier avec effectivement
des exercices qui permettent de
comprendre ce qu'elle basket il ya aussi
dans ce cadre là un atelier de
discussion avec une joueuse de haut
niveau pour leur montrer un petit peu
qu'est ce que c'est que le sport de haut
niveau comme on peut y parvenir le
département des yvelines est le premier
de france en termes d'évolution de
licenciées féminines avec 12%
d'augmentation 2013 et peut-être que
parmi les 180 jeunes filles présente ce
mercredi certaines fouleront les
parquets du département dans les
prochains mois
vous êtes revenu encore il ya quelques
semaines en fin de compte un du maroc et
de cette 17e édition du 4l trophy ce
raid humanitaire je le rappelle réservé
aux étudiants qui traverse l'espagne et
le maroc et vous êtes tous les deux
entiers de ce raid florine briard et
marc roze bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être là tout d'abord première question
en tant que passionné un petit peu de
mécanique j'ai envie de savoir si la
voiture a tenu le choc
elle aboutira a tenu le choc oui on a
juste eu un petit souci de jaune culasse
au retour sur le retour on était en
france donc en soit c'était moins grave
que si c'était arrivé avant alors on va
parler un petit peu de classement quand
même même si l aventure humaine qui
comptait beaucoup pour vous vous avez
fini je vais le dire mais 38e sur mille
quatre cent vingt équipages le
classement évidemment mars n'était pas
la priorité non non pas du tout nous on
était un peu comme cela dit le notre
camarade de tout à l'heure des finisher
on voulait vraiment finir on s'était
préparé au juste qu'on a pu entre
guillemets avec les moyens qu'on a donc
c'est nous qui avons tout fait quand
vous préparez la voiture qui était
d'ailleurs l'un de nos premiers dont un
maître de stage que j'avais eue qui m'a
offert la voiture et on a vraiment
préparé laventure pour pouvoir
satisfaire au mieux les attentes des
écoles et autres actions qu'on a un
qu'on a mené on voulait finir surtout
c'est l'essentiel et qui a conduit dans
les herbes principalement parce que j'ai
vu sur les images que vous nous avez
donné tous les deux un petit peu tous
les deux je pense que la proportion
s'attend aux 50 50
florine c'était votre second 4l trophy
il ya eu l'expérience de 2013 vous a
aidé à peut-être aider l'équipage sur
cette année 2014 complètement on a faim
comme je connaissais déjà un peu la
conduite sur le sable j'ai plus un guide
et marque sur sur la façon de conduire
dans le désert cela dit il m'a appris
aussi sur
les ans sablage ça n'a pas été trop dur
et dribble mais
et terribles mais qu'est ce qu'on aime
ça
vous a quand même pas donner des cours
de mécanique et de conduite non ce côté
là c'était plus moyen stx vous on va
parler évidemment de cet enjeu
humanitaire parce que je sais que c'est
quelque chose qui vous tenait à coeur
vous êtes parti avec 150 kg de
fournitures c'est quand même énorme dans
la dans la petite 4l comment s'est
passée justement le bas le don de tout
ces fournitures on a eu la chance
d'avoir une école qui nous a beaucoup
aidés avec une association
qui se bat pour le sport pour les
handicapés pour les jeunes handicapés
est donc cette école a beaucoup beaucoup
participé et ils nous ont d'ailleurs
tous tout ramener et une partie est venu
d'un centre commercial dans lequel nous
avons eu la chance de de pouvoir montrer
notre notre notre raid démontrer notre
projet
donc voilà il 150 mais on avait la
voiture qu'il fallait on a une voiture
une fourgonnette rallonger qui nous
permettait de pouvoir remplir la voiture
à ce point là on s'attendait pas en
avoir autant qu'ils sont d'accord parce
que la norme logiquement sur 4 l trophy
c'est plus 50 kg voilà c'est ça
alors on se dit à côté de cela et vous
avez rencontré du coup les enfants à qui
vous avez pu offrir toutes ces
fournitures floride oui mais ça a été
l'un des moments forts du 4l trophy la
remise des dons ça nous a permis du coup
de rencontrer les enfants de voir qu'au
final c'est pas totalement inutile que
qu'on a quand même un impact sur lorsque
la rizza sion s'il y avait un moment à
retenir autre que celui là j'imagine que
c'est déjà un moment fort pour vous quel
serait t'il en sort elle marque la nuit
passée dans le désert quand on est
entrés vraiment tard on sait tous
s'entraider et de nuit en 4 l on voit
déjà pas grand chose deux jours mais
leur de nuit non c'est un super moment
savait pas quand est-ce qu'on allait
rentrer on savait pas comment non plus
on savait pas si on allait réussir à se
désensabler mais c'était super tout le
monde s'est entraidé et finit par
arriver c'est l'essentiel et dernière
question rapidement vous repartez
l'année prochaine ensemble peut-être
peut-être pas encore défini mais on y
chante
le 4l trophy c'est plus au programme
maintenant mais autre chose pourquoi pas
un autre aide nous devons agir très bien
merci beaucoup à tous les noms on suivra
ça de près version in qui vous êtes un
je le rappelle d'origine guyancourt
toise tout près de chez nous merci
beaucoup à tous et bonne continuation
sur le désert peut-être en tout cas il
vient d'entrer dans la légende du
cyclisme sur piste j'en parlais dans les
titres de cette édition le nouvel hymne
y montrent un froid sauf françois pervis
a décroché trois titres de champion du
monde en colombie il ya quinze jours il
signe là un triplé historique et inédit
il nous a accordé une longue interview
vérité morceaux choisis images de
jonathan vilma et sabrina seeking
françois bonjour merci de nous recevoir
et de prendre quelques minutes dans
votre rue du temps je sais qu'il est
très chargé en ce moment tout d'abord
première question qu'on voit les trois
médailles sur votre genou que vous avez
ramené de la colombie et de cali
j'imagine qu'il n'y a qu'un seul mot ses
félicitations et bravo ouais merci bah
oui forcément
trop médaille d'or c'est un trip est
unique puisque je suis premier demi
soeur de mon sport a gagné les trois
épreuves individuelles donc j'avais
annoncé avant de partir c'était mon
objectif j'ai réussi à le faire et ça
n'a pas été une chose simple forcément
et moi c'est forcément je suis super
content est ce que vous êtes conscient
d'être entré dans la légende de votre
sport parce que trois médailles d'or
dans un même championnat du monde ça
s'était jamais fait auparavant c'est le
grand chelem des épreuves du sprint que
vous avez réussi c'est incroyable non
oui c'est incroyable alors
non je me rends pas forcément compte
encore
ce qui me fait me rendre compte de
peut-être un peu quand même c'est toutes
les sollicitations médiatiques
elles sont vraiment incroyables
à la fédération et m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient jamais vu ça par le passé donc
forcément c'est un triplé unique puisque
je suis premier à l'avoir fait dans mon
sport les trois épreuves individuelles
je pense que peut-être que aujourd'hui
je m'emporte forcément encore compte
après trois titres mondiaux vos deux
records du monde maintenant le seul
objectif qui vont eux qui vont rester et
médailles olympiques
j'imagine que maintenant tout est tracé
chez vous pour aller vers ces jeux
olympiques de rio ouais c'est sûr j'ai
deux records du monde quelque chose que
tout le monde ne peut pas avoir
maintenant voilà j'essaie 3 3 médailles
d'or il me manque la médaille d'or en
vitesse par équipes mais c'est sûr que
maintenant après tout ça c'est leur
olympique simon manque chez les jeunes
vous avez des comptes et les jours
l'aller mois jusque jusqu'à rio pour un
hors jeu pour l'instant je ne prends pas
la tête j'emmagasine je me je savoure
tout ce qui m'arrive en ce moment encore
aujourd'hui voilà je pense encore à la
télé donc c'est super
j'ai beaucoup de choses à faire encore
avant de les jeux olympiques il reste
deux ans il peut se passer énormément de
choses je peux même cassé un fémur brisé
le dos je peux être en méforme je peux
avoir une maladie on sait jamais on sait
jamais deux ans c'est long un terrain
d'entraînement mais bon c'est sûr que
les jeux olympiques quand on dit que
c'est dans deux ans les sélections ne
commencent déjà à l'année prochaine donc
forcément avec tout ce qui m'arrive
j'ai énormément de confiance j'ai
confiance en tout ce que je fais donc
après il voyait juste à optimiser
optimiser tout ce qui reste à optimiser
parce que malgré tout il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et
en termes d'entraînement en terme de
deux staffs en termes de dévolution du
matériel et
il ya encore du travail parce qu'il faut
c'est une perpétuelle évolution
perpétuelle progression le le sport de
haut niveau merci beaucoup françois de
nous avoir accordé si quelques minutes
et à bientôt sur la piste pour de
nouveaux exploits merci vous paraît le
plaisir merci
tout d'abord place aux baskets et c'est
officiel malheureusement les féminines
de l'entente de chesnay versailles
retrouveront la nationale 2 la saison
prochaine seulement un an après l'avoir
quittée lors de la 21e journée de n les
joueuses de stéphane drolet se sont
inclinés sur le parquet de brive 76 à 61
une défaite qui a scellé
mathématiquement leur sort et leur
relégation vous allez le voir au
classement les versaillais reste reste
donc à cette 11e place avec 26 points à
une longueur du 10e rennes premier non
relégable malgré une victoire lors de
lors de la dernière journée les
yvelinoises ne pourront pas passer
devant les rennaises à cause de leur
goal avérage particulier chez les hommes
le week-end a été contrastée trappe
s'est imposé sur le terrain de l'amicale
laïque du césaire levillain 73 51 et
l'entente le chesnay versailles s'est
incliné à domicile face à malakoff soit
74 à 82 les deux clubs sont
respectivement septième et huitième de
leur poule en football 17e journée de
promotion d'honneur guyancourt toujours
11e relégable recevait le quatrième
vincennes au stade maurice baquet à vrai
dire pendant 90 minutes il n'y a pas eu
grand chose à se mettre sous la dent les
guyancourt toi ne se mettront pas
vraiment dangereux ou sauf sur coups de
pied arrêtés sans réussir toutefois à
cadrer leurs tentatives les joueurs de
jus de talmont rose se sont finalement
fait surprendre sur l'une des rares
occasions 20 seynois score final 1 à 0
une défaite qui enfonce un peu plus le
sg dans cette poule de ph ça devient
inquiétant bien sûr que le maintien d
être très très difficile ça se trouve ça
va jouer vers les dernières journées
donc oui c'est inquiétant il va falloir
se battre ou v u à 3,4 équipe qui va qui
vont qui vont jouer sur leur cause sur
les derniers matches donc on va rien
lâcher et puis on veut pas descendre
dans combat se battre
betteraves continue d'être en courant
alternatif pour le compte de la 17e
journée également les trappistes se sont
inclinés sur la pelouse de quincy
voisins 1 à 0 et perdent deux places au
classement et sont désormais 8e en
football féminin le chemin de croix
continue pour montigny en division 2
lors de la 16e journée les in monte et
non une nouvelle fois subi la défaite
aux allures de score de babyfoot 5 à 0
toujours lanterne rouge de leur poule
avec seulement deux victoires cette
saison la relégation ne fait plus aucun
doute pour les saint-quentinoises
handball la belle aventure en revanche
continue pour les moins de 18 ans de
plaisir en championnat de france les
joueurs d'alexandre taillefer ont
réalisé une performance de choix ce
week-end en battant le vice champion de
france en titre rien que ça dunkerque
après une entame de match très
compliquée les plaisirs oies sont
rapidement mené 15,7 et al'inverse de
leurs précédentes rencontres ils vont
tenir physiquement en seconde période
pour prendre les devants et s'imposer
finalement 29 à 25 ils restent
quatrièmes de leur poule en volleyball
12e journée de régionale et montigny 6e
recevait le quatrième mort c'est chevry
au complexe pierre de coubertin les
joueurs d'abdellatif niche qui y ont
encore joué avec le feu après s'être
imposés 25 21 dans le premier set il
laisse échapper un second set
d'anthologie 32-30 aux visiteurs ils se
reprennent dans la troisième manche
gagnée 25 23 mai lésigny montain son
pouce et un dernier set tie-break qu'il
remporte finalement 15 11 avec cette
victoire ils remontent à la cinquième
place du classement or la requête 12e
journée de nationale 2 on suit
évidemment elancourt et une belle
deuxième victoire de la saison pour les
chocs ce sur le terrain de la
roche-sur-yon 6 buts à 3 foot us lors de
cette quatrième journée de championnat
de france élite et l'encours a prouvé
qu'elle était bien l'équipe de ce début
de saison avec quatre victoires en
autant de matches grâce à trois tonnes
jeunes notamment que vous allez voir de
geoffrey nicolas antonoff au tonic ou 20
pardon et jérémy laroque les templiers
se sont rapidement mis à l'abri s'impose
finalement 25 7 face à des niçois privés
de leur quarterback américain blessé
avec cette nouvelle victoire combinée au
match nul des black panthers les
templiers s'empare de la tête du
championnat
et puis pour terminer une petite info
vtt et le vélo-club d'elancourt de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est vu attribuer
l'organisation des championnats de
france fsgt de 2016 compétition qui se
déroulera évidemment sur la colline
d'elancourt point culminant
d'ile-de-france s'élevant à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude toujours aussi capricieux
pour les coureurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi ce 7,8 sport
qui se touche à sa fin excellente soirée
sur tv fils à la semaine prochaine